estamos interesados en estudiar la
relación entre la cantidad de horas que
estudian unos amigos para su examen y la
calificación del examen donde la
calificación está entre 0 y 6 lo que
haremos será ver los alumnos que
hicieron el examen y graficar la
cantidad de horas que estudiaron y su
calificación para cada uno de los
alumnos
por ejemplo este punto representa a un
alumno que estudió una hora y obtuvo
como calificación 1 en su examen después
vamos a ajustar una recta de regresión
esta recta de azul es la recta de
regresión para estos cuatro puntos y
esta es la ecuación de la recta de
regresión
ahora hay un par de cosas que debemos de
tener en mente normalmente cuando
hacemos este tipo de análisis lo
haríamos con más de cuatro puntos la
razón por la cual me quedaré con cuatro
puntos es que en realidad vamos a
calcular a mano que también se ajusta
esta recta de regresión a ellos
generalmente esto no se hace manualmente
para eso tenemos computadoras ahora la
forma en la que vamos a medir que
también se ajusta esta recta de
regresión a estos puntos tiene varios
nombres uno de los nombres es desviación
estándar para residuos este nombre que
tenemos aquí y otro es la raíz de la
desviación cuadrática media algunas
veces abreviado como ered de gm también
a veces lo llaman raíz del error
cuadrática medio lo que haremos es que
para cada punto vamos a calcular el
residuo después lo elevaremos al
cuadrado
y después tomaremos la suma de todos
estos residuos al cuadrado déjenme
escribirlo tomaremos la suma de los
residuos al cuadrado
y después lo dividiremos entre el número
de puntos que tenemos menos 2
en vídeos futuros o en clases más
avanzadas de estadística
platicaremos el por qué se divide esto
entre n
2 pero está relacionado con la idea de
que aquí estamos calculando un
estadístico e intentamos estimar el
verdadero parámetro lo mejor que se
pueda y en m2 de hecho lo hace para
terminar de calcular la raíz de la
desviación cuadrática media tenemos que
sacar la raíz cuadrada a todo esto
algunos de ustedes reconocerán una
fuerte semejanza entre esto y cómo
calculamos la desviación estándar
muestral al principio de nuestro avance
en la estadística y es más te animo a
que lo pienses ahora vamos a calcular la
mano como mencioné al principio del
vídeo para ver cómo funciona la raíz de
la desviación cuadrática media y para
hacer esto voy a hacer una pequeña tabla
por aquí digamos que este
es nuestro valor x después voy a tomar
ayer por acá tendremos allí sombrero
recuerda 10 sombrero será igual a 2.5 x
2 y por último tendremos el residuo al
cuadrado que será nuestro valor 100
menos que sombrero esto elevado al
cuadrado
es decir nuestro valor real - nuestro
valor estimado y esa diferencia la vamos
a elevar al cuadrado después tomaremos
la suma de todas estas diferencias y
dividiremos esa suma entre n
2 y al final le sacaremos la raíz
cuadrada a ese valor así que empecemos
por el primer dato tengo el punto 11 1,1
y ahora cuál es el valor estimado de la
recta de regresión bueno cuando x es
igual a 1
tengo 2.5 por 12.5 que multiplica a 1 y
esto menos 2 bueno pues esto es lo mismo
que 2.5 menos 2 lo cual es 0.5
ok y nuestro residuo al cuadrado será
bueno tengo 1 menos 0.5 esto elevado al
cuadrado y esto va a ser lo mismo que
0.5 elevado al cuadrado que es 0.25
muy bien ahora me voy a fijar en este
dato que tengo aquí donde x vale 2 y
lleva le 2 estoy en el punto 2,2 ahora
nuestra estimación de la recta de
regresión cuando x es igual a dos serán
2.5
esto por 2 - 2
y esto es lo mismo que bueno 2.5 por 25
menos 2 y 3 por lo que nuestro residuo
al cuadrado
serán 2
-3 esto elevado al cuadrado lo cual es
menos 1 elevado al cuadrado lo cual es 1
seguiremos con este punto que tengo aquí
si observas estamos en el punto 2 3x
vale 2 y que vale 3 nuestra estimación
de la recta de regresión serán 2.5
por dos menos dos y esto es lo mismo que
bueno como vimos acá arriba 3
y por lo tanto mi residuo al cuadrado va
a ser cero tres menos tres lo cual es
cero al cuadrado esto es lo mismo que es
cero y podemos ver que ese punto está
sobre la recta de regresión así que
nuestros residuos era cero por último
tengo este punto de aquí donde x vale 3
y vale 6 x vale 3 y llévales 6 es decir
en este alumno estudio tres horas y
obtuvo de calificación 6 en el examen y
nuestra estimación de la recta de
regresión es decir lo que espera obtener
con base en la recta de regresión será
2.5 2.5 por 3 el valor de x menos 2
esto es lo mismo que bueno 3 por 2.5 es
7.5 menos 2 es 5.5 5.5 y ahora nuestro
residuo elevado al cuadrado me quedara 6
menos 5.5 5.5 esto elevado al cuadrado y
eso es lo mismo que bueno 0.5 elevado al
cuadrado que es 0.25 ok y ahora nuestro
siguiente paso es sumar todos los
residuos al cuadrado así que déjenme
escribirlo así la suma de todos los
residuos elevado al cuadrado me va a ser
igual
y si lo sumamos obtendremos 0.25 más uno
es 1.25 más 0.25 es
punto 5
y si dividimos esto entre n 2 bueno esto
es lo mismo que 1.5 entre tenemos 4
puntos
entonces dividiremos entre 4 menos dos
lo cual es 2
por último tomaremos la raíz cuadrada de
esto y esto nos darán bueno la raíz
cuadrada de 1.5 entre 2 que es lo mismo
que la raíz cuadrada de tres cuartos o
la raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 2 podemos
incluso sacar una calculadora para
encontrar este valor en su forma decimal
pero lo importante es que esto nos dice
que también se ajusta la recta de
regresión entre más cercano sea este
valor a cero tendremos un mejor ajuste
de la recta de regresión y entre más
alejados estemos de cero
se ajustarán
y cuáles serán las unidades para la raíz
de la desviación cuadrática media bueno
dependerá de las unidades que tengas en
el eje que en este caso es la
calificación así que ya está por este
vídeo es todo nos vemos en el siguiente